[Music]
the first postulate was the harmony of
morality and objective nature the final
purpose of the world the other the
harmony of morality in the sensuous will
the final purpose of self-consciousness
as such the first then is harmony in the
form of an implicit being the other in
the form of being for self but what
connects as middle terms these
postulated two extreme final purposes is
the movement of actual conduct itself
they are harmonies whose movements and
their abstract distinctiveness have not
yet developed into objects for
consciousness this occurs in the
actualities in which the sides appear in
consciousness proper each as the other
of the other the postulates arising from
this now contain the harmonies both in
and for themselves whereas previously
they were postulated only as separate
one being in itself or implicit and the
other being for itself or explicit
paragraph 604 is considerably shorter
than the two paragraphs preceding it one
of which goes on for almost two pages
and there's a lot going on in those
paragraphs but there's also a lot going
on in this paragraph once we scratch the
surface because what Hegel is doing is
now he's laid out these these two
different postulates that are governing
moral consciousness and its action and
the relationship between duty or
morality on the one side and something
else presented as its author also
presented as something that is a sort of
freedom which we subsume under this term
nature but also include in terms of
happiness glueck or glue Klee kite right
and also in terms of the will the will
in the sense a natural will which has
fundamental desires or drives
Timon right and certain inclinations
nagging so how is Hegel bringing this
stuff together here you notice that he's
going to talk about a first postulate
and a second postulate and now he's
making things very clear for us in a
rather schematic way so he reminds us
the first postulate was what the harmony
of morality and notice what he says here
he doesn't just say morality and nature
he says morality and objective nature
gag and certainly a nature had become an
object for the moral consciousness not
just sort of an inchoate ground
something that isn't known
and this really does reflect a a nature
understood I would say in a very modern
sense as a field of essentially
mechanistic processes or at least law
governed processes so he does have in
mind something
Kant's notion of nature or in the
Newtonian you know many other modern
philosophers conception of nature as
well and this harmony is very important
and why is it a postulate let's remind
ourselves of that because it doesn't
actually exist
yet it's not there in nature it's not
there in the totality of moral
consciousness or morality and nature put
together it has not yet been achieved
it's not yet been made actual and Hegel
will talk about this as a final purpose
and ends Veck in german and that's that
strikes us as a little bit funny in
English right because and can is a
translation of Zek so in a way it's
saying an end end a final end the end
which motivates the other ends which is
sort of functioning like an attractor to
them you could think of it that way or
as is something that is is leading them
to their final state where they're most
fully developed a world that is most
fully developed would in fact be a world
in which morality and nature were in
harmony I thought was we've seen of
course in the last paragraph if we were
to attain a state where there was a
complete identification or coincidence
between morality and nature then we
would lose the moral consciousness a
harmony doesn't necessarily have to be
an identity think of a harmony of notes
right the first is not the third is not
the fifth but together they comprise a
harmony that we call a major chord so on
the one side we have this first
postulate harmony of morality and
objective nature the final purpose as
Hegel tells us here of the world of the
totality things that
which includes us as things within the
world
she says the other the second postulate
is the harmony of what morality and the
sensuous Xin Lika will the will insofar
as it is not pure will sort of an
abstract conception or something that's
also within us in a cottonwood say new
mental as opposed to phenomenal fashion
which means we can never really wrap our
heads around it let alone our our
fingers and yet it's there according to
cons and in essence according to Hegel -
even if it's not being made actual it's
still there
in potentia in latency you might say but
the sensuous will is one that we're very
familiar with when we examine ourselves
what it is that we do in fact desire
like right now I desire to shoot a video
on Hegel right I also desire to have a
bit more coffee
I also desire to you know do all sorts
of other things those are all part of my
sensuous we could say world bound will
and these are connected with each other
the will is in part how we as
individuals as human beings interface
with reality it's not just through our
intellects it's not just through our
senses it is through our desiring our
striving our choosing our preferring our
dis preferring all of those things are
ways in which we are involved with a a
world so this is something worth keeping
in your back pocket and thinking about
later on now Hegel goes on and he tells
us not only do we have this postulated
harmony between the morality and the
sensuous will where a will could in fact
be brought in line and have the right
kind of inclinations not go against
morale
the way that we find ourselves doing he
calls this the ends back the final
purpose of self-consciousness as such so
now we have two final purposes and we
have two postulates we have two
harmonies how does this hold together so
he goes on and he says we have a middle
term let's look at the text itself what
connects as a middle term these
postulated two extreme final purposes is
what the movement he says of actual
conduct itself isn't that an interesting
thing to say the movement the bagel of
actual conduct veer clickin Honda lands
what it is that we actually do not just
what we will not just what we think not
just what we know what we in fact do
what it is that we choose what it is
that we prioritize how far we see it
through that is the vital connection
that binds these two postulates together
and offers them any possibility of being
actualized and such so the possibility
of morality and the world of nature
being harmonized the possibility of
morality and this you know crazy will
that we have as individuals being
harmonized lies in action lies in
conduct in doing something so he says
these are harmonies whose moments in
their abstract distinctiveness have not
yet developed into objects for
consciousness where does this occur
Hegel tells us this occurs in the
actuality in which the sides appear in
consciousness proper each as the other
of the other so each of these is you
might say a piece or a object
of our consciousness we're lending them
space in our heads and each of them is
taking on a certain kind of subjectivity
each can be an other to the other each
of them is taking on a certain kind of
agency they're becoming something like a
drive so he says the postulates arising
from this now so we have a new set of
postulates right
what are these postulates these
postulates now transform through action
into having a genuine other in our moral
consciousness the postulates arising
from this now contain the harmonies both
in and for themselves
he says whereas previously they are
postulated only as separate one being in
itself or implicit the one over here and
the one being for itself or explicit now
why does he say implicit and explicit
well you know is this typical Hegel
playing around in the categories of in
itself or it's off in and for itself you
know the third term here no there's
something more to it what do we
experience more directly the the lack of
harmony of morality with the world
environment earier conflicts that we
ourselves have in trying to fulfill the
moral law and finding ourselves being
driven all sorts of other places by the
actual will the dispositions the
inclinations the drives the desires that
we we do in fact have and then having to
push against that's much more explicit
that is for itself this is in itself it
has to be called out but it doesn't take
too much to do that and the you know to
bring this to a close the vital
connection in not between them as in
itself but making them in and for itself
is going to be some sort of conduct or
action
the moral consciousness as the simple
knowing and willing of pure duty is in
the doing of it brought into relation
with the object which stands in contrast
to its simplicity into relation with the
actuality of the complex case and
thereby has a complex moral relationship
with it here arise in relation to
content the many laws generally and in
relation to form the contradictory
powers of the knowing consciousness and
of the non conscious in the first place
as regards the many duties the moral
consciousness in general heeds only the
pure duty in them the many duties qua
manifold are specific and they therefore
as such have nothing sacred about them
for the moral consciousness at the same
time however being necessary since the
notion of doing implies a complex
actuality and therefore a complex moral
relation to it these many duties must be
regarded as possessing an intrinsic
being of their own further since they
can exist only in a moral consciousness
they exist at the same time in another
consciousness then that for which only
pure Duty QWOP your duty possesses an
intrinsic being of its own and is sacred
paragraph 605 is another short paragraph
in comparison to 602 in 603 there's some
important stuff going on here and it's
it's a bit of a jump from the previous
paragraph into this one we're going to
see all of these threads being brought
back together shortly but not in
paragraph 605 so what is he goal
discussing here we start out by talking
about the moral consciousness again and
he says the moral consciousness can be
understood as we have previously as the
simple knowing vision and simple willing
Voland of pure duty and where did we get
this simple willing and knowing from all
the way back in the absolute freedom and
the terror section that was the
culmination consciousness in the
transition to moral consciousness was
realizing itself as pure knowing and
pure willing and somehow there being you
might say not a pure coincidence of
these but them being integrated with
each other so where do we go from from
there he says in its doing and we saw
that doing or handled was this third
integrating term in the previous
paragraph here Hegel's not talking about
that but he is referring us back by
using the same term in this doing of
pure duty it's brought into relation for
help this with the object now here's
where it starts to get very interesting
which stands in contrast to its
simplicity its eine Fock height its
one-sidedness it's not actually
one-sidedness and such anxiety kite but
having one aspect to it having one way
of being what is opposed to that
duplicity actually that's going to come
up as a section later on no not
duplicity multiplicity
monic faulty kite or in its adjective
form here modding fault again having
many different aspects having many
different relations many sides not all
being able to be grasped at once
something is einfach simple you can
grasp it as a totality at once if
something is complex or many-sided or we
might even say ambiguous then it can't
all be grasped at once and you struggle
to put it all together so the object of
duty in action when we start trying to
actually do our duty in the real world
or on ourselves to go back to the
previous paragraph when we're trying to
bring about some sort of harmonization
between morality and the world or when
we're trying to bring about some sort of
harmonization or
successful integration between morality
and its demands and our screwed-up wills
that we have to you know use to get
themselves in line with morality
whenever we're doing that we are
engaging in action in cases we don't
just do it in general we do it in this
case in this case in this case in our
lives
you know this is something that
Aristotle had pointed out way back in
ancient Greece we can certainly
generalize about moral phenomena we can
come up with rules they only hold for
the most part why well because they have
to apply to specifics they have to apply
to individuals to particulars and when
we get to the level of complex cases are
nice clean neat rules our duties in this
case I flicked up right don't always
hold so nicely their shape we can say
they're they're neat contours so let's
go on with this he says it stands in
relation
and in contrast with the actuality of
the complex case
so the actuality the vehicle a kite the
being real the stuff we encounter of the
complex monic fault again case fall
there's kind of a play on words there
monte fault again fault right what it is
that we're actually encountering so if I
may have a general duty not to lie and
then I'm encountering one of those
tricky situations let's take a you know
sort of hypothetical thought experiment
first right what if there's a crazy
murderer and he is asking where the
babies are so he can go in and kill all
of them do you tell the murderer who you
can't actually stop by your own means
where the babies are or do you'd lie to
him and tell tell them that the babies
are on the other side of town it can get
much more concrete than that that's a
still a rather abstract you know nice
simple thought experiment what if it's
it's somebody who you actually know and
they want to use some some drugs and
they know that they're in the house
somewhere and they're an addict and
you've been through this many times with
them and they say really they just need
to even themselves out because they're
really jonesing for it and you know they
also have to hold down a job and they
need to function and maybe just this one
time you could let them have it but just
a small amount to tide them over but
then that might lead to them you know
continuing out and see how it gets very
complicated very quickly so this is an
important point isn't it that that
morality is not quite so simple to
impose upon ourselves or the world
through knowing and willing as we would
like to think so he says in relation to
content the stuff the many laws
generally and in relation to form the
contradictory powers of the knowing
conscious consciousness and
of the non-conscious this is how they
arise so in in content we have like you
says all these different laws all these
different obligations all these
different duties that were faced with
and in relation to form there's
something unconscious wouldn't be forced
going on here he doesn't actually follow
up too much on that at this point but
that's worth pointing out so now he goes
on and he says in the first place as
regards the many duties
what is the moral consciousness pay
attention to the moral consciousness in
general heeds only the pure duty in them
so it tries to see within each of these
specific duties that has to do with a
specific case a real-life situation it
reads the general simple duty into it
and that can be sometimes quite
successful and sometimes can be markedly
unsuccessful or even paradoxical or can
cause all sorts of other problems now
Hegel goes on and he says these many
duties as many are as manifold as as
different from each other are specific
and therefore as such have nothing
sacred nothing holy nothing absolutely
morally compelling about them for the
moral consciousness the way that this
simple notion of willing and and and
knowing Duty does but he says at the
same time being necessary these duties
are still duties so they are necessary
in some sense since the notion of doing
implies a complex in actuality and
therefore a complex moral relationship
to it these many duties must be regarded
as possessing an intrinsic being of
their own so we've already got a problem
here we're gonna have a second problem
coming up very quickly but let's point
out this problem we have this nice neat
conception of beauty that's very simple
we can wrap our head
around it I mean think about Kant's
categorical imperative you know sounds
great Act only I'm the maximum that you
can at the same time will to be a
universal law of nature boom there it is
or act always so as to treat humanity in
your own person and that of others never
as a mere means but always does it ends
great it's very abstract what happens
when we get down to the nitty-gritty of
particular cases you know and we do
start and start doing applied ethics all
right and we start thinking as nurses or
engineers or media consultants or
friends and neighbors or parents or
children or we could go on and on and on
it starts to get very murky and that's
when we have a tendency to start saying
well I don't know how I fit it under
this rubric of general duty but I know I
have a duty to do this and there's
there's a tendency to start saying well
maybe we get rid of the general concept
and we just enumerate our duties this is
by the way is what professional codes of
ethics typically do right they'll have a
few general principles and you ask any
of the practitioners one of those
general principles mean and they're like
hum on a homina homina iro you know
don't ask me what fidelity actually
means or or you know non-maleficence
actually means but then you get down to
specific things okay if a child is
showing signs of sexual trauma you need
to report it to these authorities I'm
thinking about Lina like a psychiatric
or psychological association or Medical
Association or really that I'm going to
be bound on teachers or police or
whoever then you have to report it
that's a specific duty now the question
then is how do we bring these together
successfully the very general abstract
simple duty and the real-life duties
that we in fact encounter face feel
ourselves bound by that resolved here
but that's being raised second issue
comes up in the last sentence further is
these specific duties since they can
exist only in a moral consciousness
that's something worth pointing out
there's no such thing as a duty that's
out there like in the
by itself without being in any sort of
moral consciousness at the very least if
it's you know in a book and we all have
died off and somebody else is reading
the book there they're encountering
moral consciousness through that book
right they exist at the same time in
another moral consciousness all right
and what moral consciousness do they
exist in they existed another
consciousness than that for which only
pure duty qua pure Duty possesses an
intrinsic being of its own and is sacred
so we have a split within moral
consciousness taking place we have a
self and other dynamic starting to occur
and now we have to see where that goes
you